however infections are anything special
they just fracture which you've been
dealing with the years as they happen
have algebra I did that you also know
how to do it uncle
so this is really just a set for the
sake of practicality because some people
would questions like this and they do it
well they treat it as very differently
to a question like this looks to a lot
of people are okay with the second
question you want a glass the motive
numbers and they look at the first one
the one without rabbit freaked out okay
it's no reason to do that all the rules
of work with fractions work with
algebraic fractions okay so let's have
to be clever if you had a half minus or
seven what would you do to help you
actually evaluate that so what we want
to suggest I think I want to call the
denominator between the two fractions
because right now crashes in a different
denominator because I'm talking
different languages so they won't mix in
this case what is the best common
designer to choose for things like a TV
which just multiplies the cross and I
guess you know pocket it's exactly the
same up here I'm going to make the
denominator 14 might be suggest look at
the first term and onto sorry I'm sorry
how do i what would know what about
someone by to change that to donate on
it
187 right so I'm gonna multiply the top
and the bottom happy look real ready I'm
going to do the same with the next term
what I multiply by something different
since it has a different remote
nominator
what about the money I won by the two I
encourage you say in your head and on
the paper to write it goes / - 400 -
because you just multiply back so you
actually change the fraction two men on
seven is not in effect I'm on my by two
on two the numbers are all the same
wonderful I have the same thing of it is
so now is that let me do
it allows you to do the subtraction by
combining two into one so I'm going to
write the Sabbath and now I'm going to
write extra language you can probably do
in your head that will become very
useful but you look at these further
examples I'm going to combine the
numerators and I'm going to combine the
julies like that okay are you happy with
that
that makes sense now I just want to
point out this is really big want to try
my plan a very common error when going
from this line to this line is for early
students to write seven eight minus two
n on the top and it's right 28 although
now you do not to do that you're blind
when I wrote the 14 why is it not 28
because you've got to 14 right we build
a fraction is like highlighting decimal
it's like you're adding the two made
from the top because the 14 would be one
being one
aha okay so this thing down here the
Dominator don't behave the same way that
the numerator does it is related to the
rules
here's the way that I would do dread
it's quite similar to that if you have 4
over 1 plus 5 over 1 this is the third
one without your student I've just put
more clothes on
we know affordable one is we don't find
everyone is but we know you don't say oh
that 9 and that's 2 because that's not
true is it
it's just going so just remember because
you're going to get out and run out here
and even though it's obvious that these
four teams that covers even 14 with as
imagiro the bottom people often make
this result this error even in each
other okay have a look down the bottom
again I need a common denominator what's
it going to be 44 a wave is your drink
one note on this all of that let me
introduce you by the way a fancy word
you don't need it but it's really
helpful just unluckily to in denominated
and I want you to draw it imperative to
them and I'm going to give you a name to
describe these these know that ecause
co-prime
know what it means for the number is
prime yeah it's something with the
status right like 24 is not prime
because you can faster eyes with lots of
numbers all right i5 on the island is
prime because you get over g5 & 1 now
it's not prime but together they're
Cupra they don't share any factors right
do you see if I would change that 5 into
a 6 you could do a common denominator of
48 it still worked but there's a better
choice what is it if you had like a
person that just like over here right
I'm looking for a common no identity 24
would be perfect because I've been both
like this 1 by 4 and for once like this
1 by 3 on 3
do you see why it's different 6 & 8 are
co-prime right do you see they share a
factor what's the factor this you hurt
someone it's too right so since these
guys share a factor you can multiply the
DNA of 48 divided by the common factor
gives you 24 that's the best choice okay
here they don't share any common factors
so what do you do well you just want fun
that's it just like in the first example
as well okay so we're going to change
the denoted is all 240 what's the first
action B and yeah I'm multiplying by
five on five yeah so that's going to be
five M on 40 and now they look like this
would buy one on one hey hey okay eight
for eight you saw good usable division
okay so now the guys are talking the
same language but I notice the
numerators it has they don't like turns
so what would work fine delight be 1 and
then minus it and that's it you don't
know
okay right lastly camp one this is going
to be a challenge to get all today but
pointed out try to warm you up
with these simple words so here we know
exactly what to do
we rehearse this twice already the last
by hand
what's the first step to make progress
with this question school Corbin to
dominate our three and five commented on
a will be 15
if this wasn't going to say right I'm
going to multiply this fraction over
here top and bottom by 3 now watch out
I'm going to put the faculty in college
I might you put some brackets on top of
this fraction and the other fraction I
encourage you to do the same because
what else you recognize is the next line
is 3 and plus now it's very common to
write 6 right now why don't you people
read 6 because look I multiplied it by 3
look see 3m it's not 6 is it is because
you multiplied the whole thing
the entire numerator by 3 which is why
you can multiply the entire denominator
by 3 as well second fraction multiplied
by water 1 5 on 5 so this is going to
become 5 plus good you got both of them
on good ok
there are one last time I'm going to
write the brackets because remember we
said oh you multiply pendous by 3 you
will find this and this by fire you see
this bloater sized it applies to
surprise surprise this and this entire
fraction so very common error would be
to write 3 and plus a 2 you take away 5
and plus 10 that's a very common error
what's gone wrong
yeah I didn't apply but - so this guy I
just did it to this one which is a
problem so I'm going to fix that up and
then zip it for Salinas and that's
divided by 50 what can I do now to tidy
up then the video yes I'm going to
connect like terms I think these guys
alive turns your free animals you take
away five and so how many you do anyone
yeah negative two and what about the
numbers plus looks to me like hey I
think you can take with you on in this
case we're done the last three our check
is that often often sort of jazzy
everything around and everything being
simplified sometimes do how to combat
between here and here like if this was
phase twelve if this were twelve
eighteen what could I do
further I could divide everything
everything by two right so that would
become - and lots for because remember
we've done it like three times now it's
important to plot / and then you go okay
any depth we actually need there were
two a color backers so your personality
okay